Cuando pensamos en Brasil
lo más probable es que nos vengan a la
cabeza cosas tan típicas como la samba,
la caipirinha, el Cristo de Corcovado o
playa es tan increíbles como Ipanema o
Copacabana.
En definitiva, el sitio perfecto para
desconectar.
Sin embargo si le preguntáramos a un
brasileño puede que la imagen de su
país no sea exactamente ésa. Hoy en VisualPolitik te contamos la parte menos
bonita de Brasil.
Brasil está sufriendo hoy su peor
recesión desde los años 30 o quizás la
mayor de todos los tiempos. Sólo en el
primer trimestre del 2006 el PIB cayó
un 5,6% respecto al mismo
período del año anterior.
Brasil está replicando su década
perdida de los 80 en tan sólo dos años.
En cuestión de dos años el número de
desempleados ha pasado de 7 millones a
11. La crisis y la caída en el precio
del petróleo ha afectado a la
recaudación de impuestos de forma
severa.
De hecho el actual gobernador del estado
de Río de Janeiro, Francisco Dornelles,
declaró el pasado 17 de junio el estado
de "calamidad pública".
"El objetivo del decreto es presentar a
la sociedad de Río de Janeiro
las dificultades del estado abriendo
camino medidas duras"
El déficit previsto
para el Estado de Río de Janeiro este
año es de 5.600 millones de
dólares, un 30 por ciento de sus ingreso,
parece que el problema comenzó cuando en
la época del boom del petróleo se dedicaron a
subir salarios y pensiones haciéndolo
ahora insostenible.
A día de hoy maestros, médicos
policías y bomberos tienen problemas
para cobrar sus salarios.
"Bienvenidos al infierno: la policía y
los bomberos no cobran su salario,
cualquiera que venga a Río de Janeiro no
estará seguro". Para que os hagáis una
idea la cosa llega hasta el punto que la
morgue de la ciudad de Río (de Janeiro) controlada
por la policía estatal dejó de aceptar
cuerpos a principios del mes de junio
porque no tenían dinero para hacerse
cargo de la limpieza tenían que mandar
los cadáveres a otras ciudades. Tremendo.
Como recordaréis en las próximas
semanas se celebrarán las olimpiadas de
Río 2016 y esta situación ha afectado
de lleno a las Olimpiadas, el Estado de Río de
Janeiro es el responsable de la
seguridad y de la construcción del
metro que une la villa olímpica con el
centro de la ciudad, y no está del todo
claro que pueda estar en funcionamiento a
tiempo. El gobierno federal se ha
comprometido a mandar unidades militares
para reforzar la seguridad
aún así el problema no parece del todo
resuelto y algunos como el famoso jugar
brasileño Rivaldo están pidiendo a la
gente que no arriesguen su vida por ir a
ver las Olimpiadas. Las olimpiadas han
sido, por cierto, otro gran escándalo
en Brasil y es que la Policía Federal
ha incluido dentro de la Operación CarWash,
el mayor caso de corrupción
investigado de la historia del país, varios
proyectos milmillonarios relacionados
directamente con las olimpiadas.
Los encargados de esta macro operación
están investigando a importantes
políticos del país como el
expresidente Fernando Collor, el presidente
del senado Renan Calheiros, y el que más
revuelo creado el ex presidente Lula da
Silva, que fue detenido el pasado mes de
marzo relacionado con operaciones de
lavado de dinero.
La situación política en Brasil es en
estos momentos el todo inestable, el
pasado 12 de mayo el senado brasileño
suspendió a la presidenta Dilma Rousseff
del cargo por un período hasta 180
días acusada de manipular datos
oficiales de la contabilidad del gobierno.
Mientras que el 63% de los
brasileños valoran el gobierno de
Rousseff como "malo" o "terrible" con el
peor índice además de aprobación de un
presidente brasileño desde el año 92,
bueno pues Dilma denuncia que se ha
cometido un golpe de estado contra ella.
"Lo que está en juego
es el respeto a la voluntad soberana del
pueblo brasileño,
el respeto a las urnas". Michel Temer
vicepresidente del gobierno de Rousseff ha sido
designado mientras tanto como presidente.
Temer ha sido criticado nada más llegar
por nombrar un gobierno compuesto sólo
de hombres y además blancos. Aunque
lleva escasamente unas semanas en el
poder dos de sus ministros han tenido
que dimitir ya relacionados con escuchas
en las que criticaba a los
investigadores del caso CarWash. Uno de
ellos era el encargado de luchar contra la
corrupción.
En materia económica los planes de
Temer son claros: recortar al máximo
posible el gasto desorbitado del gobierno
que ha credido a un nivel del 6%
durante los últimos 20 años y
luego tratar de dar seguridad a los
inversores internacionales para atraer
nuevo capital al país.
¿Vosotros que creéis? ¿Los políticos de
Brasil serán capaces de acabar con la
corrupción generalizada en el país? ¿Es
razonable que un país
en esta situación se gaste miles de
millones en construir todas las
infraestructuras necesarias para celebrar
durante unos días unas olimpiadas? Sin
duda deberemos estar atentos los próximos
meses a las noticias que nos lleguen
desde Brasil si nos ha preocupado el Brexit, nos debería preocupar mucho más
aun un hundimiento sin retorno de la
economía brasileña. Espero todos vuestros
comentarios, si os ha gustado el vídeo dadle a "like" y suscribiros al canal si aún no
lo habéis hech para estar al tanto de nuestros
nuevos vídeos. ¡Un saludo y hasta la
próxima!